pour commencer il faut d'abord se
présenter nom prénom âge
présentation sommaire qui plonge déjà
les candidates dans le bain plutôt à
l'aise laurine 19 ans répond avec le
sourire aux questions de culture
générale
même si elle n'a pas toutes les réponses
est ce que vous connaissez le président
du conseil d'éthique de la matinée
pendant ce temps là dans la salle
d'attenté logan accompagnée de sa maman
attend un peu stressé son passage prévu
dans quelques minutes
j'ai jamais participé à deux castings
jamais défilé
donc du coup c'est un peu une
appréhension puisque c'est nouveau pour
moi déjà c'était une surprise et je
trouve que c'est un super challenge
et voilà et je ne peux qu'être fier de
quelque qu'elle accepte de relever ce
challenge est de retour sur le plateau
télé ou laureen entame la dernière ligne
droite
le défilé en maillot passage obligé mais
pour cette candidate la chorégraphe à
une demande spécifique des filets sur la
pointe des pieds
j'ai menti qu'elle avait des petits
soucis d'appui donc je voulais m'assurer
que ce n'était pas dû au talon et
qu'effectivement il y avait des petites
choses à travailler et bien là il serait
maintenant temps de demander à leur
hymne comment elle a vécu cette
expérience
il est très bien vécu est vraiment une
expérience nouvelle mais qui restera
toujours positif pour moi et s'il y
avait parmi les filles une candidate
totalement à l'aise ce serait sans aucun
doute pauline 20 vérifier après la très
importante étape de la toise sont ils au
menton voilà elle répond de manière
détendue aux questions qui peuvent
paraître banal mais qui ont toute leur
importance
[Musique]
comme on tue qu'on te démarquer des
autres c'est une bonne question comment
je compte me démarquer des autres je
pense pour ma part ma personnalité je
suis quelqu'un d'ambitieux et je pense
que c'est important surtout pour des
concours comme celui de miss france
mais si certaines jeunes filles tiennent
encore à se présenter à cette élection
d'année en année leur nombre ne cesse de
diminuer les critères de sélection c
et c'est très carré il ya de plus en
plus de jeunes filles
avec des tatouages et des piercings bon
il y en a de moins en moins très fine
aussi le dernier casting qui
sélectionnera les finalistes du concours
miss martinique aura lieu le 23 juin
prochain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]